(light liquid pouring)
(gentle sipping)
- [Narrator] For morning
coffee to afternoon tea,
caffeine is so thoroughly
entrenched in our daily routines
and has become the worlds most widely used
psychoactive substance.
Caffeine is a chemical compound
that stimulate the central nervous system.
It accomplishes this by attaching itself
to adenosine receptors in the brain.
In doing so, it blocks
adenosine molecules,
which are responsible for slowing down
the central nervous
system before we sleep.
The result?
Adenosine cannot regulate
and neurons start firing.
This results in a person's reduced fatigue
and increased alertness
and cognitive performance.
Side effects many seek
by consuming caffeine.
Caffeine occurs naturally in coffee beans,
tea leaves, cacao beans
and some tree nuts.
People have been consuming
it for centuries.
But dailY consumption
took off sporadically
at different times in different
places around the world.
Coffee became popular in
the 15th and 16 centuries.
But Cacao was used among early
Mesoamerican civilizations
hundreds of years earlier.
Tea became popular by the 14th century
in China during the Ming dynasty,
but didn't catch on in Britain
until almost 400 years later.
Today, caffeine can be
found nearly everywhere
and more and more
caffeine-infused products
are hitting the shelves everyday.
In the United States,
nearly 90% of the population
has at least one caffeinated
beverage everyday.
Up to 400 milligrams of caffeine
per day or about four cups
of coffee is considered safe for an adult.
Too much caffeine for any one
person can cause side effects,
such as migraines, insomnia,
nervousness and muscle tremors.
One tablespoon of pure caffeine equivalent
to drinking 75 cups of coffee at once
can have lethal consequences.
Due to this risk of
caffeine overdoses, in 2018,
the United States Food and
Drug Administration banned
the bulk sale of products containing pure
or highly concentrated caffeine.
While caffeine may provide great benefits,
such as increased focus,
alertness and energy,
it comes with considerable risks
just like any other substance.